bonjour alexis et j'espère que vous avez
apprécié ce que j'ai montré sur notre
antenne heureuse de vous retrouver dans
la matinale de france alors emmanuel
macron at il franchi un cap dans la
communication politique avec cette vidéo
youtube
réalisé avec mc fly et carlito disons
qu'ils utilisent les outils de son temps
on se rappelle les campagnes auparavant
n'y avait pas forcément les réseaux
sociaux donc mma qu'on se met en scène
avec ses deux influenceurs youtube qui
était anciennement employés de webedia
ils sont maintenant à leur compte mais
cette opération était monté de à
l'époque de webedia c'est une opération
de com a entièrement montée par par
l'elysée on voit bien d'ailleurs la
façon dont on appelle comme ça m bape et
tout ça est scripté entendu on parle de
foot c'est un sport que tout le monde
connaît très populaire on essaye de
parler aux jeunes le président essaye de
parler aux jeunes de se donner une image
positive
ça ne fait pas oublier les nombreux
jeunes qui étaient en train de faire la
queue devant les banques alimentaires le
refus d'avoir un revenu minimum pour ces
jeunes
les phrases du président mais un costume
si tu veux travailler il faut traverser
la rue on est dans une opération de
communication de propagande même
politique à l'ancienne avec cet
entourage c'est cet habillage en fait
des réseaux sociaux qui est plus nouveau
puisque le premier à en avoir fait
vraiment un usage permanence c'était
obama
et c'est depuis devenu un passage
nécessaire pour tous les politiques donc
c'est un exercice de propagande et rien
d'autre il faut le remettre à sa place
pour ce que c'est c'est à dire de la
communication a sévi depuis ce qu'on ne
touche pas le fond il faut rappeler les
chiffres de la précarité de la pauvreté
en france
ce n'est pas cette opération de
communication qui va y changer quoi que
ce soit et le vote des jeunes en ligne
de mire est ce que c'est une entrée en
campagne qui ne dit pas son nom
finalement oui clairement on voit que
depuis quelques semaines emmanuel macron
essaye de parler à ces jeunes qu'il a
totalement perdu
l'idée c'est de se poser en grand
libérateur en disant ça y est vous
pouvez aller dans les bars vous pouvez
aller au concert on l'a vu à nevers
saluer les jeunes très sage un concert
de rap en disant voilà c'est grâce à moi
maintenant si vous pouvez retrouver
notre liberté que je vous avait
confisqué pendant tous ces mois faute au
virus dira-t-on et le voilà qui avec de
faux le jeune max icarly taux qui sont
quand même relativement rage et essaye
de parler mais bien la plateforme du
tout aux plus jeunes de football mais
d'autres choses opération de com encore
une fois avec eux ce faux concours à
égalité ou le président devra mettre un
portrait de michael et carlito sur son
bureau pour l'allocution du 14 juillet
on croit rêver et où les deux youtuber
sont invités à prendre place dans un des
jets de la patrouille de france donc on
est encore dans une opération qui va
durer dans les semaines qui viennent
le pass culture pour parler à la geneste
c'était une promesse du candidat macron
qui est tenue qui est rappelé en ce
moment parce qu'il ya les régionales
mais surtout ce qui est en ligne de mire
évidemment c'est 2022 et on voit bien
que c'est une campagne qui commence et
qui va aller très loin dans la
propagande dans la manipulation dans la
façon dont on va utiliser les réseaux
sociaux bien briel attal porte parole du
gouvernement lui aussi est un des grands
influenceurs de ce gouvernement présents
sur tous les réseaux sociaux pour parler
aux plus jeunes il ya le s est mis aussi
qui va avoir lieu cet été donc
clairement les jeunes sont la cible de
cette campagne de communication initiée
avec cette vidéo de mcfly carlito
stratégie des influenceurs des notes
telle une peur des journalistes aussi et
et des médias par le président sortant
oui plus qu'une peur une méfiance voire
une certaine haine on a vu les
déclarations d' emmanuel macron par
rapport à la presse on le sent
d'ailleurs très mal à l'aise avec de
vrais journalistes
c'est un président qui ne tient
quasiment jamais de conférence de presse
très rarement qui choisit à qui il donne
des interviews
rappelez vous il interviewera brut où il
parlait de violences policières puis
ensuite à vers l'heure actuelle et puis
le voilà avec mike lake erie tôt mais
quand il est question de répondre à des
vraies questions de vrais journalistes
il ya plus personne d'ailleurs un des
influenceurs qui avait été invité par
gabriela talent le disais mais pourquoi
vous nous invitez nous pour vous poser
des questions c'est pas notre métier de
poser des questions donc on aimerait
davantage de conférence de presse
davantage
finalement deux confrontations avec de
vrais journalistes pour avoir des
réponses à nos questions qui sont celles
de la sortie de crise bien sûr de
l'endettement massif de la france et
puis deux
du sort vraiment de la jeunesse réservé
par emmanuel macron s'il était élu s'il
était candidat et réélu en 2022 parce
que là cette communication
finalement qui n'est que dans la forme
ne touche jamais le fond et c'est là où
ça fait mal
ce gouvernement comme ce président ne
sont que dans l'exercice
communicationnel jamais dans la
gouvernance
merci beaucoup alexis pour votre édito
ce matin on vous retrouve avec plaisir
comme tous les lundis